[Musique]
encart semestre bonjour bonjour venu au
bistrot du théâtre monsigny je vous en
prie ministre du théâtre à
montigny-le-bretonneux qui nous
accueille une nouvelle fois pour le café
politique de recevons les différents
élus pour parler un petit peu de leur
parcours et de leur engagement vous êtes
maire de coignières vous êtes également
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis peu un maire sans
étiquette mais votre majorité est plutôt
une majorité de droite vous avez pris la
tête de la commune de coignières s'était
officiellement le 11 avril 2015 après le
départ surprise d'henri pailleux qui lui
était maire depuis 1986 ça fait donc un
peu plus d'un an que vous êtes à cette
responsabilité-là un petit peu moins ou
un peu moins
bientôt un an bientôt un an comment vous
avez vécu ses premiers mois en tout cas
ce sont des premiers mois qui sont
enthousiasmants qui sont enthousiasmants
parce que prendre la suite d'henri
pailleux après 29 ans à la tête de
coignières c'est quelque chose
d'enthousiasmant c'est quelque chose de
passionnant mais c'est quelque chose
d'assez difficile tout de même remplacer
une personne qui resté aussi longtemps à
la tête d'une commune c'est assez
difficile
j'ai été j'ai été parrainée par par
henri payet qui m'a kim a parrainé à
cette occasion et je suis avec une
équipe qui est
qui est très très très touché je dirais
et donc qui me permet d'avancer sur les
différents projets que j'ai sur son
poignet et je dirais que un an passé qui
a passé très vite
on va peut-être venir tout de même sur
l' annonce du départ d'henri pas lieu
parce que ça a été une surprise il l'a
fait au moment de ses voeux ses voeux de
fin d'année il a dit qu' il passerait la
main en tout cas qu'il quittait à la
commune pour plusieurs raison de
désaccords on va en parler plusieurs
choses qui l'avait contraint en mai mais
au moment de l' annonce déjà vous étiez
un petit peu dans la confidence est ce
qui vous en avait parlé
ce qui c'était prévu qu'ensuite vous
seriez mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
j'étais un peu dans la confidence mais
très peu très peu dans la confidence est
temps que l' annonce de la démission
d'henri pailleux n'était pas fait lors
de ses voeux effectivement je n'avais
pas la certitude de la passation de les
sharp et l'équipe a suivi dans le sens
dans ripaille eu effectivement pour me
désigner pour me choisir pour lui
succéder effectivement pas eu de
concurrence pour savoir qui allait
prendre ensuite il ya pas dans l'est pas
il n'y a pas eu de concurrence au sein
de l'équipe toute l'équipe était
favorable à ma candidature pour
poursuivre à la tête de poignard on va
re préciser aussi tout de même que vous
n'avez pas découvert à ce moment là la
commune de coignières entrée au conseil
municipal à ce moment là puisque vous
avez intégré l'équipe municipale alors
je vérifie tout de même les dates parce
que ça fait une quinzaine d'années
c'est d'abord en charge de l'urbanisme
ensuite de l'économie comment vous êtes
arrivé tout simplement en politique déjà
le je suis arrivé je ne suis pas arrivé
tout à fait en politique je suis arrivé
au sein d'une équipe municipale parce
que je suis seulement faire de la
politique vous fait la différence et je
fais la différence entre les deux je
suis une liste qui est apolitique et je
ne je suis au café politique mais je ne
suis pas tout à fait à une personne
politique c'est vrai que je suis une
personne qui s'est intéressé qui
s'intéresse toujours à la gestion
municipale est maintenant à la gestion
intercommunale bien sûr mais je suis
d'une personne une personne de
local si vous voulez je n'ai pas de
carte actuellement mais j'ai une
sensibilité de droite
effectivement une sensibilité de droite
marquée et mon équipe est apolitique
quand vous dites actuellement vous
n'avez pas de faire ça veut dire vous
êtes opposé la question ça c'est un
choix ferme et définitif ce n'est pas un
choix à faire mais définir pour évoluer
ça pourrait évoluer ça pourrait évoluer
c'est vrai que j'ai un penchant
sensibilité de droite les républicains
c'est vrai mais je n'ai pas de carte
actuellement dites-vous venait justement
de la commune de cognin c'est comme ça
que vous vous êtes intéressé un petit
peu oui je passais vous arrivez avec un
moment joignait j'arrivais en 1974 à
coignières et donc j'ai vu l'évolution
de coignières depuis 1974
à l'époque il y avait 12 cents habitants
il y en a maintenant 4500 donc au cours
de toutes ces années j'ai vu
effectivement l'évolution et j'ai
profité de du passage de la de la vie
active à la vie de retraité pour me
mettre à la disposition de l'équipe
municipale menée par henri payeur à
l'époque bien sûr en 2001 et l'évolution
de cette commune de coignières la passe
aussi par sa réintégration au sein de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ça aussi on va
en parler dans bien sûr et du café
politique je vous propose de passer en
salle à présent vous remercie poursuivre
la conversation vous en prie
[Musique]
ans
jean pierre sauvestre ont évoqué à tout
à l'heure votre arrivée à la tête de la
commune et le départ d'henri pas eu
aussi l'ancien maire depuis 1981 686
tout à l'heure il l'a dit au moment de
son départ qu'il ne quitterait pas
complètement la vie politique et pas la
vie de la commune non plus quelle place
ils occupent aujourd'hui et bien
lorsqu'il a
annoncé son départ le 31 janvier 2015
il a annoncé effectivement qu'il
conservait la vice présidence au sein de
la communauté de communes des étangs
vice présidence chargée
je crois de développement économique et
il conservait également une place au
sein du conseil municipal de coignières
au sein également de la commission
finances et puis une place également
dans différents organismes que nous
pouvons avoir au sein de la commune vous
échanger régulièrement il est là pour
continuer à passer le relais ou est-ce
qu'elles sont son empreinte est encore
très forte sur les valeurs sont son
empreinte je vais dire préalablement
monsieur cailleux est parti pour
différentes raisons notamment
l'intercommunalité puisque en 1984 la
commune de coignières a quitté la ville
nouvelle
comme vous le savez est notre mère
allait notre maire henri pailleux donc
qui a pris la commune en 1986 était très
attaché effectivement au départ de guan
hier de la ville nouvelle
alors donc effectivement la perspective
de réintégrer ce qu'on appelait la casse
qui n'ont pas forcément beaucoup plus
gris forcément il y a un côté très
difficile à accepter
et donc c'est une des raisons pour
lequel henri payet est parti
l'autre raison je pense également c'est
l'état de santé de ripailles eux qui
avaient besoin aussi de se reposer et
puis également quelques notions de
politique générale qui il froisse est
assez blasé des gaules a lassé de la vie
politique à l'émission politique matin
est donc monsieur cailleux est parti
pour ces raisons mais je pense que dès
les premiers les premières semaines
lorsque j'ai pris là
le poste de maire de coignières monsieur
cailleux souhaitaient participer
également à aux différentes réunions aux
différentes aux différentes préparations
qu'il pouvait y avoir pour notre
intégration au sein de ce qui s'appelle
maintenant saint quentin en yvelines et
donc ce que je ne souhaitais pas pour
les raisons que je viens de vous exposer
c'est à dire que monsieur cailleux était
partie pour cette raison
donc vous avez récupéré la municipalité
la tête de la municipalité en cours de
route
or autant vous n'avez pas l'intention
d'être d'être transparent sur la sur la
suite du mandat vous avez marqué tout de
suite vous avez pris tout de suite vos
marques tout de suite se démarque parce
que je pense que je prenais
effectivement la tête de la commune en
tant que maire ans le 11 avril à 11
heures comme le souhaitait effectivement
mon prédécesseur et donc je ne
souhaitais pas effectivement ensuite que
mon prédécesseur est une empreinte trop
forte sur moi et puisque nous avions une
perspective d'intégration de dans saint
quentin en yvelines et donc à partir de
cet instant effectivement il a été
difficile d'avoir des relations je
dirais des relations faciles pour cette
raison pour cette première dame était
impératif mais avec en epire le nous
sommes résistants conçus encore
aujourd'hui nous sommes un peu en
conflit est faite en novembre avec avec
henri pailleuse que je déplore
énormément mais ce que je comprends
également parce que henri paillet
pendant 29 ans a servi la commune de
toute façon extraordinaire et donc nos
relations tendues me
me contrarie me contrarier actuellement
bien sûr mais je pense que lorsque nous
ceux d'une personne est restée aussi
longtemps à la tête d'une commune rester
pour la suite
c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile je pense pour la personne qui
souhaite rester mais pour lui la
personne qui le remplace pour le succès
ce soir c'est difficile
voilà pour moi c'est très difficile je
ne pense je pense que je dois assurer je
dois assurer mon poste et donc mon
prédécesseur aurait pu effectivement me
donner des conseils mais ça n'a pas été
le cas ça n'a pas été le cas ça a été
plutôt des relations qui sont qui sont
devenues tendues effectivement et sa
branlée l'ensemble de votre majorité au
sein du conseil d'une bonne balle pas du
tout j'ai une majorité qui resterait
unis puis qui est très uni etats unis
j'ai une majorité qui est très uni mais
je déplore effectivement la situation
qui ce qui est celle actuelle parce que
effectivement j'ai une opposition
l'opposition habituel c'est-à-dire le
groupe poignard pour tous mais j'ai
maintenant une opposition effectivement
une nouvelle opposition constituée par
mon prédécesseur henri pailleux ce qui
est dommage ce qui est dommage
actuellement oui ça nous pénalise pour
travailler sur les dossiers sur sur la
commune justement au delà du fait
d'avoir aussi des conseils d'être
accompagnés mais ça il ya toute une
équipe avec vous êtes une équipe avec
moi avait sur lui pour avancer sur
différents dossiers c'est ça c'est
difficilement nous nous avançons nous
avançons en sérénité si vous voulez sur
les dossiers effectivement il y à
l'intervention d'henri paille en conseil
municipal
des interventions effectivement sur ce
que nous devrions faire et ça n'est pas
toujours ce que ce que nous faisons
effectivement mais c'est ce qui vous met
mal à l'aise on a rencontré ce qui me
met mal à z
effectivement mais nous marchons
sereinement tout de même oui bien sûr
sur la question de l'intercommunalité
justement qui était le point le plus
triste est le point le plus
vous la vivez vous cette réintégration
au sein de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
donc le retour de coignières ou à
travers certains de cette nouvelle
interco contrairement donc à mon
prédécesseur et maintenant je vais
parler effectivement pour ce qui me
concerne pour ce qui me concerne je
considère qu'à partir du moment si vous
voulez où nous avons une loi des arrêtés
préfectoraux qui nous qui nous impose
l'intégration dans une nouvelle
intercommunalité
je pense qu'il convient de rentrer d'une
façon positive dans cette
intercommunalité
j'ai une idée de l'intercommunalité qui
n'est pas non plus très très positive au
départ parce que je vais t'en sens déjà
je pense que l'idée est très bonne mais
je pense que nous avons du mal en france
à appliquer ce type de choses il y à des
mutualisations qui devrait être fait et
qui sont très difficiles à mettre en
place
et puis il y a bien sûr et le côté
politique également qui est très
difficile aussi à assumer parfois et
donc l'intercommunalité quelque chose le
principe est très bon mais il est
difficile à mettre en place et nous
constatons effectivement actuellement au
sein de saint quentin en yvelines
parce que comme vous avez pu
voir nous avons un recours effectivement
sur la nomination de été déposée par le
déposée par l'opposition et des membres
de l'opposition pour la nomination du
président des vice présidents et de
renoncer les hommes une hauteur il y
aura une nouvelle élection
alors il y aura probablement une
nouvelle élection ce qui n'est pas
encore décidé pour l'instant je pense
que la décision devrait arriver
rapidement
mais je pense qu'effectivement il y
aurait une nouvelle une nouvelle
élection rapidement et ce qui devrait
apporter je pense tout de même un peu
plus de sérénité au sein de au sein de
l'équipe maintenant coignières environ
4500 habitants c'est une commune urbaine
alors moitié secteur urbain et puis
motrices de nourrir râle parce que l'on
connaît beaucoup de coignières tout ça
tout ça perspective le long de la
nationale 10 avec toutes ces entreprises
commerces qui sont implantées mais ce
n'est pas uniquement ça il ya aussi
toute une partie rurale
vous voulez préserver cette partie
rurale justement vous voulez voulant
conserver au sein de 50 ans o'neal a
effectivement je présente souvent
coignard également mois pour comme
commune urbaine mais ce sont vos besoins
comme jérôme brielles mais nous avons
effectivement 45% je crois de notre
superficie qui est représenté par la
zone urbaine de paris encore nous sommes
en limite de zone urbaine de paris
et puis 55% qui sont représentés par des
zones agricoles et puis par des zones
boisées essentiellement propriété
d'ailleurs de la maison dassault et nous
voulons conserver effectivement cette
cette notion parce que lorsque vous
quittez cette nationale 10 et vous
rentrez dans coignières pour aborder la
place de l'église de la mairie là vous
rentrez dans un centre de village
effectivement et faut le conserver
nous avons actuellement l'élaboration de
notre plan local d'urbanisme qui est en
cours et je pense qu est et c'est une de
nos préoccupations de conserver d'abord
le caractère vieux village centre ancien
de conserver la zone urbaine la zones
densifiées d'habitation telle qu'elle
est actuellement est de conserver le
côté rural le côté agricole puisque nous
avons encore une ferme dans notre ville
dans notre village une ferme et 2 les
champs qui y sont attachés alors si ce
qui est presque en opposition avec ce
qui est mis en avant aujourd'hui de
saint quentin en yvelines ce côté terre
d'innovation terres territoires
d'excellence pour les entreprises
l'économie est beaucoup mis en avant
c'est la volonté de la nouvelle équipe à
la tête
et lorsque lorsque nous étions en dehors
de saint quentin il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça
j'avais une image et j'ai toujours tout
de même une image effectivement telle
que vous l'avez décrit que c'est à dire
une image de sièges sociaux de grandes
entreprises et ce qui est très bien de
développement économique avec thales
avec safran avec toutes les grandes
toutes les grandes entreprises mais je
pense que l'un ne doit pas empêcher
l'autre et donc nous avons aussi au sein
de notre
communauté d'agglomération douze
communes nous avons maintenant des
espaces verts des espaces naturels qui
sont à mettre également en évidence qui
sont à apporter à l'image complémentaire
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et je pense
qu'il y a un projet de territoire au
sein de saint quentin en yvelines a
préparé à constituer réaliser et je
pense que c'est un des des gros travaux
que nous devons avec les 12 maires
réalisés au cours de trois années à
venir et vous arrivez à vous faire
entendre parce que vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure vous de voir si la diva
politique vous vous estimez pas comme un
politique et on le sait au sein des
intercommunalités c'est toujours
intéressant de faire un peu de politique
bon comment vous positionner par rapport
à juin
je me positionne tout de même avec une
sensibilité de trois et ça je le dis et
je ne peux pas me mes délires et donc
effectivement je me trouve dans la
majorité
telle qu'elle est actuellement constitué
des huit communes de sensibilité de
droite ou de droite vraiment déclaré
avec des personnalités telles que jean
michel fourgous etc ou des personnalités
qui sont vraiment politique mais je me
situe effectivement dans la majorité
actuelle de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
ça ne me pose pas spécialement de
problèmes actuellement de ne pas être
j'ose pas le mot encarté mais d'avoir de
ne pas avoir de carte de parti politique
c'est un gros mot en clarté
non non mais c'est un mot que vous ça
vous plaît pas forcément à sa phase de
conception d'être mère et de gérer une
connu une attaque aussi peut être
l'étymologie du mot c'est tout
simplement vous propose d'écouter un
petit micro-trottoir ça nous allait dans
votre commune écoutez les réactions de
quelques administrés ce qu'il pensait de
la politique que vous meniez dans la
ville est très bien payé assez peu de
temps qu'il a succédé à monsieur
cailleux l'ancien maire je sais pas mais
moi je pense qu'il saura défendre nos
intérêts 1
surtout avec la terre comme réalité rien
n'a changé depuis une dizaine d'années
ici il ya pas mal de trucs qui ont
changé à commencer par des parterres et
puis la propreté ainsi un peu plus oui
peut-être
il ya peut-être des choses à voir au
niveau du commerce de proximité c'est
vrai qu'il est peut-être là fait
beaucoup de choses au niveau de sécurité
on est vraiment là franchement on est
tranquille par rapport à l'installation
des caméras et tout c'est une réponse
sur les commerces de proximité je vous
ai vu acquiescé oui tout à fait un
dossier important
c'est un dossier important c'est un
dossier important dans le cadre de notre
plan local d'urbanisme notamment puisque
nous avons un petit centre commercial à
proximité de notre résidence des acacias
centre commercial qui qui se disent
l'une qui devient désert bien sûr les
commerces de proximité à soignies arabes
y en a partout
c'est un partenaire tout les quand même
du bien et les hypermarchés sont de
proximité à coignières pour ses
habitants
cette proximité et donc nous avons une
priorité au sein de notre plan local
d'urbanisme c'est d'étudier
effectivement l'évolution de ce quartier
pour remettre en
en activité ce petit centre commercial
wiki qui actuellement peine et qui a du
mal à qui ne vit plus actuellement on
peut le dire au sein de saint quentin en
yvelines vous êtes vice président vice
président en charge du sport le sport
parce que je suis un ancien sportif sans
être de haut niveau je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas fait de performance chronométrée
extraordinaire mais j'ai fait beaucoup
de courses à pied j'ai fait de la marche
et j'ai fait beaucoup de vélo et donc
le sport m'intéresse le sport
m'intéresse d'abord pour le côté
physique du sport mais il m'intéresse
également pour son côté convivialité
pour son compte et rapprochement de
personnes 2 2
de milieux différents pour les côtés 3e
mi-temps aussi parfois on peut dire pour
le côté si vous voulez le sport c'est
quelque chose qui doit apporter un lien
donc y'a un média social
il ya un côté social vient coter ce
seuil les prix tout à fait pencher
plutôt du côté social c'est bien ils
vont vos engagements politiques tels que
social je ne vois pas le rapport non
cotées sociale noté non mais le côté
social parce qu à vous écouter vous
parler du lien vous parler oui pour
tenir ce n'est pas ce n'est pas une
exclusivité du parti socialiste de
parler du lien fait général c'est plutôt
quand on oppose cédric mans les deux
formations et c'est vrai très économie
il ya un côté plus culture loisirs très
portées par la gauche
oui oui en général c'est cette
opposition est prêt mais je ne suis pas
opposé du tout à la gauche lorsqu'il
parle de liens de liens sociaux etc
je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable et à l'heure actuelle je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
absolument prioriser absolument nous
sommes dans une période et je voudrais
rendent hommage d'ailleurs aux victimes
et aux familles des victimes des
événements qui sont déroulées ces jours
derniers à bruxelles et à nos amis
belges je pense qu'il faut avoir une
pensée
effectivement comme le effet aussi en
novembre dernier ont une pensée pour
nous comment vous voyez l'évolution
justement des rapports au sein de votre
commune parce que moi peut-être
s'arrêter sur ça vous disiez ce
important de créer du lien créé et du
social il ya plusieurs types de
populations de différents maux et bien
sûr coigné assurer le lien entre toutes
ces populations nous et nous essayons de
créer un lien entre toutes les
populations et nous essayons de créer
des événements pour faire pour faire ce
lien nous avons créé d'ailleurs l'an
passé la fête des voisins
nous avons favorisé la fête des voisins
au sein de la résidence des acacias
je souhaite effectivement que c'est de
cette fête des voisins soit pérennisée
par une association au sein de la
résidence ce week-end que des personnes
prennent en main pour permettre de
pérenniser ce cela mais nous avons aussi
cette année nous avons la foulée
couleurs la foulée sportif qui va être
faite au mois de mai nous avons encore
un moment
un moment de convivialité la fête
communale rassemble aussi beaucoup de
monde à la fête communale qui se
déroulent parfois sur deux jours parfois
sur un jour nous avons des modifications
de de programmation mais nous avons de
nombreux événements bien sûr le forum
des associations qui rassemble également
l'ensemble des associations mais nous
avons nombreux événements qui permettent
de créer un lien mais il faut accentuer
ce lien et je pense que je suis très
sensible au vivre ensemble parce que à
notre époque c'est indispensable de
créer des liens avec les différentes
communautés et je suis très sensible
justement à recevoir les différentes
communautés qui peuvent être sûrs
coignières également ça peut passer par
le sport notamment vice président en
charge en charge du sport à saint
quentin en yvelines le sport la
politique sportive c'était d'aider
toutes les associations de favoriser
justement l'intégration il n'y a pas d'
équipe de très haut niveau qui porte les
couleurs de saint quentin en yvelines au
niveau national par exemple
sam d'aller faire là aussi un petit
micro jours s'il attendait justement qui
est une équipe qui représente un peu ce
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
au plus haut niveau
mais pourquoi pas oui oui ça c'est une
bonne idée un mille fois oui je voudrais
une jours à une équipe internationale de
cricket ou alors à l'extrême rigueur du
water polo
j'aimerais l'athlétisme parce que c'est
ce qui me plaît le plus voilà c'est le
plus vivant par exemple cyclisme je
pense que c'est un très bon territoire
non seulement il ya le vélodrome juste à
côté là et en plus on a tout l'espace
qu'on veut ici chez tt ce serait bien
j'espère une belle ou du basket -
laurent d'après le foot après basket
les deux moments qui a le rugby va
franchement oui ça serait intéressant on
pourrait le soutenir comme ça une équipe
de haut niveau à saint quentin c'est
envisageable
on a un petit peu posé cette question
parce que le territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines va accueillir en tout cas la
ryder cup ce sera en 2018 ça c'est pour
le haut niveau il ya le vélodrome qui
est implanté il ya les différents
championnats du monde championnats
d'europe qui s'y déroulent une équipe de
très haut niveau à saint quentin en
yvelines
ça fait partie des projets de 50 ans et
des écoutes et pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
j'ai des questions moment que le psg
vient de s'installer sur l'île des
loisirs oui sur l'île des loisirs
c'est ça a été envisagée mais je pense
que ce n'est pas dans les projets vont
vraiment immédiat installations du psg
sur l'île de loisirs mais pourquoi pas
une équipe de haut niveau
je suis vice-président depuis depuis à
peine deux mois et je dois vous dire que
je n'ai pas encore étudié tout à fait la
possibilité d'une équipe de haut niveau
mais nous avons tout de même au sein de
des équipes existantes à saint-quentin
actuelle nous avons quand même des des
sportifs de haut niveau tout de même en
athlétisme en tennis de table dans
différentes dans différentes activités
sportives nous avons quand même des
athlètes de haut niveau et c'est ce que
nous voulons supporter notamment un pour
dent si vous voulez dans les contraintes
actuelles les contraintes que vous
connaissez au sein d'une communauté
d'agglomération actuel restait
effectivement dans les enveloppes
budgétaires mais faire mieux avec ce
qu'on a et puis éventuellement le projet
de paris
bien sûr il ya le projet jo 2024 vous
avez cité effectivement le vélodrome et
et nous avons les championnats d'europe
au mois d'octobre prochain
donc la ryder cup en 2018 les géo
pourquoi pas en 2024
et puis il y a également l'open de
france qui va se dérouler également sur
le golf national donc nous sommes tout
de même un territoire de sport de haut
niveau et ce qui est intéressant pour
terminer juste cette émission ce café
politique et peut-être quelques
réflexions quelques remarques sur la vie
politique plus nationale cette fois-ci
sensibilité plutôt à droite quand vous
voyez aujourd'hui tous les débats qui se
déroulent à droite justement pour
désigner un seul candidat au sein d'une
primaire qui ressemblerait républicain
éventuellement les centristes sauf que
les centristes maintenant décidé de ne
plus y aller quel regard vous portez là
dessus vous pensez que ça peut
réconcilier les gens avec la politique
sous sa moye je ne suis pas choqué par
le nombre de personnes qui veulent se
présenter
je ne suis pas choqué du tout parce que
chacun doit avoir la possibilité et
c'est une occasion d'exprimer ses
opinions et je pense
notamment à à notre député jean-frédéric
poisson par exemple qui al'intention
effectivement de se présenter aux
primaires
mais comment est un démocrate par qu'ils
les démocrates donc alliée des
républicains qui a qui doit se présenter
aux primaires et je pense que c'est une
bonne chose et je peux le dire pour
différents autres candidats si vous
voulez et c'est l'occasion d'exprimer
ses réflexions ses opinions et des idées
également maintenant que les centristes
ne rejoigne pas les républicains pour
ces primaires ça ne me choque pas du
tout et je veux je pense que pour moi ça
me semble plus raisonnable
je pense que le centre doit rester c'est
au centre et donc des républicains
doivent faire une primaire pour ce qui
les concerne
mais je ne venais pas la carte donc
c'est une opinion toute personnelle -
garantir mais je suis effectivement je
suis d les candidats aux primaires du
parti des républicains bien sûr les
différentes personnes et personnalités
politiques pardon de ses dizaines de
dernière dernières années quel serait
votre modèle est ce que vous avez eu ou
es ce que vous avez un modèle en
politique
écoutez j'ai ma façon de gérer j'ai un
modèle en politique je pense que je sais
gérard marché à partir de sa mère durant
président du sénat que j'ai eu
l'occasion aussi d'accueillir à mes
voeux et qui est toujours un fidèle de
coignières et jeu
j'ai une admiration pour gérard larcher
vraiment c c'est une personne
extraordinaire gérer sur sa façon
d'échanger comme vous dites mais sur sa
façon d'être disponible également sur sa
façon de soutenir sur sa façon de
d'aborder les choses sur sa façon de
voir les choses bien sûr et bon bien sûr
ça correspond également à mes idées mais
voilà c'est une personne oui c'est un
modèle pour moi
merci jean pierre semestre merci à vous
merci
[Musique]